i think i'm right in saying that you
were the first conservative to come out
against the prime minister how are you
feeling about it this morning
not much better than i was when i first
came out against the prime minister
about 18 months ago um that was long
before partygate you will recall kay
uh indeed so but he's still there isn't
he
he's still there and um as you know i've
taken a lot of flack because i have said
very clearly and very publicly that i
don't believe that the middle of an
international crisis and it is the worst
crisis since 1945
is the time to change the leader of the
conservative party but that may not be
my gift because
it looks very much as though
whatever i think events are going to
overtake that and we should see what
happens
yeah why do you think it is that so many
of your back bench
colleagues um
just still feel that he is the best
person for the job
i think in part there's residual loyalty
but also i think a lot of people do
recognize that we are in the middle of a
very grave crisis
and
the last thing we want to do is
destabilize the government of the united
kingdom and
potentially therefore destabilize the
coalition against putin's
criminal war
um when we are facing such a dire
circumstance but and it is a very big
but
if and i suspect this may happen
there are
more revelations
more
metropolitan police fines
and if sue gray's report is damning as
it may well be
then whatever i think
that ground will shift there's no doubt
about that
do you think that it all depends at the
end of the day what happens with the
local elections because if you know it
it is basically um
a view on what people think of the prime
minister um a protest vote or otherwise
and if
the conservative councillors still do
well then it's all over isn't it i mean
the prime minister just stays in post
and on we move
i don't think so um the cost of living
crisis there are a lot of things coming
down the track that are going to be very
difficult to handle
um
my hope and expectation would be that if
things get markedly worse for the prime
minister
then he will do the honorable thing and
resign now that may be um wishing the
pigs will fly
because under those circumstances i
still wouldn't want a leadership
election but i think there is a way
through this um i've suggested
publicly and nobody's knocked me down
yet
that the deputy prime minister who after
all stood in for the prime minister when
the prime minister had coveted
could take over and lead what
effectively i've described as a war
cabinet a crisis cabinet if you like
until such time as it is sensibly
possible to have a leadership election
because that election
will take three months it will be
contested and it will take out of play
effectively or take their mind off ball
key players such as elizabeth truss ben
wallace
michael gove
the deputy prime minister himself
possibly rishi sunak and many others
that is not a desirable circumstance
when you're facing
what effectively could be the start of a
world war
why do you mention rishi soon out there
given that he's also broken
the law
mr sunak is in a slightly different
position my understanding and it's only
my understanding
is that he actually genuinely went
expecting to attend a cabinet meeting
and found himself
under rather compromising circumstances
and nobody has suggested
as far as i'm aware that he's done this
more than once it looks very much as
though the prime minister's
offering to the house of commons
yesterday
may be
slightly undermined by future events and
announcements from the metropolitan
police but of course
as various of your guests have said in
the course of the morning we have to
wait and see what that brings
but the defense that you suggested there
for mr sunak in the cabinet room that's
exactly the same one as the prime
minister's used
um at the moment yes the problem is that
there may be a series of offenses on the
part of the prime minister and there's
also the full sue gray report that's
coming down the track and we have to
wait and see what that says
my personal view
is that the prime minister's situation
has been untenable for quite a long time
and i've said this very openly remains
untenable i have a lot of sympathy with
the view that mark harper expressed
yesterday
and indeed lord garnier this morning
said that the and i think it was a
a delicate phrase
said that the prime minister has an
eccentric relationship with the truth
that is true but the bottom line for me
is that we are in the middle of a very
serious international situation
and we have to get through this and we
have to get us through it europe through
it and the world through it and that
actually at the moment
for my view has to be the priority
um just tell me what the mood was like
uh in the meeting with the back bench
mps yesterday when the prime minister
was talking to you
i would be very frank with you um
i stayed for three minutes and left
i didn't storm out in half
i found the tone of the meeting from the
very beginning
um shall we say very different from the
tone in the house of commons
and i i go on expecting a serious
meeting about serious issues
i didn't expect a lot of bluster and
pantomime performance and i'm afraid
that's what i heard and it seemed to me
that my time was better spent doing
other things
could you contextualize the pantomime
performance
well
in three minutes um
all i can say is it was fairly
bear in mind the 1922 committee is
supposed to be a private meeting
um
so traditionally we don't talk about it
but it's a known fact that if you want
to publicize something you talk about it
in 22 committee and if you want to keep
a secret you make a speech in the
chamber
but that said
um
i did not like the tone of the meeting
kate
yeah i wanted to i i mean you know let's
just explore that a little bit further
if we may because obviously the the the
um
outward looking face from the prime
minister yesterday
in the commons was one of contrition are
you saying that it was much more bluff
and bluster and you know jazz hands in
the 1922 committee
um what i heard myself and bear in mind
i have to say again i was there for all
three minutes
i'm told that the meeting got more
serious later and certainly
some colleagues asked
fairly searching questions
but what i heard
i didn't care for too much
do you think he just doesn't take it
seriously enough
um i think you could say that yes
okay i've pushed you hard enough on that
it's good to talk to you thank you so
much roger for joining us on the program
thank you
thank you